You might already be planning to go trick
or treating or bingeing the new season of
Stranger Things this Halloween, but there
will also be a few freaky horror flicks worth
checking out around All Hallows' Eve.
From the return of a few major franchises
to creative genre-busters and intriguing indie
scare-fests, here are all the new horror films
that will blow you away this Halloween.
Cult of Chucky
You just can't keep an evil doll down.
Dating back to Chucky's debut in 1988, the
Child's Play franchise has spanned six films,
all with the nightmare-haunting toy stalking
and slaying without abandon.
Cult of Chucky picks up as a sequel to 2013's
Curse of Chucky, with a young woman in a mental
institution being gifted a doll that turns
out to be the hilarious plaything.
The film will bring back Alex Vincent, Chucky's
original victim, as well as Chucky's wife
Tiffany and Nica Pierce from Curse of Chucky,
and, of course, the doll that started it all.
"Hi.
I'm Chucky.
Wanna play?"
Count on this one to haunt your childhood
all over again when it hits theaters on October
3rd.
"We're friends to the end, remember?"
Better Watch Out
This Christmas-set slasher pic has already
proven to be a hit on the festival circuit.
The film might be a bit formulaic, as it features
a routine night of babysitting that goes horribly
wrong.
But critics have been especially impressed
with this holiday-themed tale of a young woman
fighting off intruders while protecting her
pre-teen charge.
So we can probably expect Better Watch Out
to give Santa's naughty list a whole new meaning
after this one drops on October 6th.
Happy Death Day
What happens when you mash up Groundhog Day
with a horror flick?
Happy Death Day aims to find out by featuring
a young woman who basically has to re-live
her birthday over and over again — to find
out who's slaying her.
"Sprinklers."
"Car alarm."
It's a teenage slasher with a clever twist,
and it could be just the thing to lure horror
fans to the theater again and again when it
arrives on October 13th.
Leatherface
The Texas Chainsaw Massacre franchise has
been going strong for five decades, so it
shouldn't be too much of a surprise that another
installment of the OG slasher classic is coming
this Halloween season.
This time, it's Leatherface, which will focus
in on the early days of the namesake villain
years before the events depicted in the original
Chainsaw.
The film aims to build an origin story around
the title character, revealing the future
psycho was once a troubled youth involved
in the mysterious loss of the local sheriff's
daughter.
He spends 10 years in a mental hospital before
escaping, and then the manhunt begins, with
the "deranged," revenge-seeking sheriff out
for Leatherface's, umm, hide.
Prepare for jump scares and gore galore when
this pic hits theaters on October 20th.
"What?"
The Snowman
Talk about a cold case.
In this crime thriller, an investigator is
reminded of a very old case when he
finds a victim's scarf tied around the neck
of a snowman and begins thawing out other
unsolved crimes  that might be related.
But by getting too snowed into the case, our
hero might find that icy glare trained on
himself and his loved ones sooner than later.
"You could've saved them.
I gave you all the clues."
Get ready to experience all the chills when
The Snowman hits theaters October 20th.
Jigsaw
The seventh installment of the Saw series
was supposed to be its last, but with so many
games yet to be played, the filmmakers on
Jigsaw turned on their tape recorder for another
round.
This time, the film will follow a new mysterious
psycho who gathers a group of victims to torture.
But while the title character of Jigsaw has
been dead for years, investigators start to
notice some striking similarities between
his original work and this new protege's.
"The truth will set you free"
These supposed copycat slayings will serve
as a reminder of the best and worst of the
prior installments and introduce some new
horrors for the trap-happy fanbase.
So, get ready to make your choice on October
27th.
"No, it's not creepy at all"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!